[Music]
aaron rodgers meeting with reporters on
wednesday just two days after that
extended interview he did on espn
milwaukee where it was a a friendly
environment for him where he was able to
address the bleacher report article in
exhaustive detail
but yesterday uh
look he he
he doubled down to a certain extent he
didn't talk about it as much as as he
did on monday but he still believes what
he believes about the situation the big
news though mark murphy the packers ceo
who had previously said nothing chris he
had an opportunity to speak about it and
some would say maybe it was a little bit
later than it should have been but
here's mark murphy talking about his
thoughts on the article that emerged a
week ago on bleacher report written by
tyler dunn
it's all in the past and a lot of half
truths and you know a lot of stuff just
made up the conversation that allegedly
took place between aaron and i was
completely false we had a great
conversation but it was very positive
and uh you know i talked about matt
lafleur and uh and said aaron you know i
think this change is going to be great
for you and the organization and it was
very positive
now remember the report from tyler dunn
was that when ceo mark murphy called
aaron rodgers to tell him matt lafleur
was the new coach
murphy said to rogers don't be the
problem don't be the problem and murphy
also reportedly tired of the divas stuff
with aaron rodgers so murphy disputed
that but he also used the word half
truths which means that there were some
truths in that article and that leads to
the other point chris that mark murphy
made regarding whether or not this story
ultimately will become a positive let's
listen to what murphy had to say
i think this is going to be a great
motivation for him and the team
you hate to have your dirty laundry
as you said aired but uh i i do think uh
it's gonna end up being a positive
yeah i i
yeah you know i
from murphy's perspective
yeah you know we went through a little
short-term pain here and yeah it stirred
up some things and yeah we'd rather that
not happen but if it makes everybody
focused and motivated and determined to
be as good as they can be in 2019 that's
a good thing right chris yeah no i mean
it is and sometimes things like these
are like this can you know again bring a
locker room together and especially
maybe even aaron rodgers reassess how he
wants to lead going forward or whatever
it may be uh yeah i do think these
things can be positive listen i'm glad
that mark murphy addressed the situation
a little bit uh because you know i
didn't want to hear about you today
because you were going to come in with
all your conspiracy theories talking
about oh the packers haven't made a
statement and this looks real fishy and
rogers must be guilty of everything so
i'm glad he got that out again i think
they were letting this die down a little
bit mark murphy didn't want to make this
the biggest thing going on in the nfl
the first day back for otas or off
season workouts or whatever it may be
but again it's a new time there it's a
new culture the bad news and the bad
laundry is gone and they're trying to
move on from that and become more
positive and a new team here going into
2019
but you do have to admit that before
mark murphy speaks if there's a vacuum
if there's nothing from the packers in
response to an article that aaron
rodgers had come out and called a smear
attack and passionately pushed back
against the likes of jeremiah finley and
greg jennings and and seems to take
issue with everything in there and he is
clearly upset about it and and if he
truly believes that it's falsehoods that
they're embellished by the reporter to
boost his career and the team has said
nothing at all at a certain point that
does become a problem and i hey i i
could see aaron rodgers look at what
mark murphy said yesterday and say man
you really didn't come out against this
thing the way that i would have
preferred you're kind of laughing it off
as hey it's going to make us better in
2019 so yeah again when you're dealing
with somebody who has that reputation a
well-earned reputation of being
ultra-sensitive you have to
strategically think about everything you
say
and i would guess that if he would admit
it aaron rodgers ultimately not happy
with the way the packers have responded
to this report that he feels so
passionately about yeah well again i
don't think that the the green bay
packers wanted to fan the flames of this
story to start out the week on monday
and tuesday and just give it more juice
i think they were doing their best to
let it die down and i'll really go back
to something you've said over the week
that i think also plays into this this
you know situation you've talked about
you know no ownership factor there in
green bay
it's not in green bay's dna in their
history at least in my observations of
them having these type of moments you
know i mean the moments i'm not saying
the little dysfunction between rogers
and mccarthy i mean the moments of where
there's a head of the organization who
comes out and makes you know state of
the union type addresses on the team
regularly you know that with the owner
and a team like mr craft or jerry jones
and the cowboys they're always at times
going to get up there in front of the
microphones and give you the state of
the union what's going on with the team
and tell you their thoughts and i think
because of lack of ownership there in
green bay a different structure you
don't get that as much and maybe they're
a little slow to react to things like
this as well
well i i just think that their
their position early on was keep their
head low keep their mouth shut and let
it just go away but but there was a
disconnect between that strategy
and aaron rodgers strategy which was go
on espn radio and milwaukee and tear
this thing apart and basically if the
team's not going to do it then i guess i
have to do it i'm just trying to read
this from the perspective of how does
aaron rodgers feel about how the packers
have handled it and mark murphy finally
has spoken but i think it's fair to
wonder given everything we know about
aaron rodgers whether or not he's upset
at some level that they didn't address
it more quickly and that they didn't
attack it more aggressively more pft
live coming at you right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports